Rumpelstiltskin
once upon a time there was a rich hat
maker
he told lots of lies but he was so rich
that nobody cared when he told lies he's
just joking they all laughed the rich
hat maker loved to go to dances with
other rich people at the dances the rich
people stood around and told lies to
each other
my husband shot a turkey from three
kilometres away said a rich lady my son
is so smart
he teaches his teachers said a rich man
my cat is so clever she fetches sticks
like a dog said another rich lady the
rich hat maker wanted to join the
conversation so he told his biggest lie
yet my daughter is so amazing she can
turn hay into gold all the rich people
nodded and smiled oh yes they said how
wonderful suddenly there was a loud
voice at the back of the room she can
turn hay into gold it was the king
everybody bowed and gasped as he walked
up to the hat maker did you say she can
turn hay into gold oh well what a mitt
was yes
stammered the hat maker bring her to me
bellowed the king he stormed out of the
room
oh dear thought the hat maker what do I
do know the next morning the hat maker
brought his daughter Sophie to a small
room in the palace Sophie was very
confused why am I here
your father is a liar explained the king
last night he said that you can turn hay
into gold I think that is a lie and I
hate liars
here is a bundle of hay please turn it
to gold it must be done by morning
Sophie gasped oh and one more thing said
the King if you fail I will feed your
father to my crocodiles I hate liars
everyone left sophie was alone oh dear
thought Sophie what do i do no night
fell sophie felt angry how ridiculous
she fumed I can't turn her into gold
it's impossible just then she heard a
strange little laugh - he what do you
have for me he a little man appeared in
a corner of the room he was very small
he had brown curly hair a black hat and
red pointy shoes he need some help my
dear he asked I need to turn this here
into gold side Sophie that's ridiculous
it's not possible oh it is possible I
can do it for you said the little man
yes please help me begged Sophie the
little man pulled two knitting needles
out of his pocket he began to knit the
hay into clothes as the hay passed
through his needles it turned into
beautiful golden thread he knitted
golden scarves he made golden hats and
golden socks soon the hay was gone and
there was a pile of golden clothes on
the floor and now what do you have for
me he asked the little man this diamond
necklace suggested Sophie perfect said
the man I need the diamond necklace
Sophie gave him her necklace
he said teehee and disappeared the next
morning the King returned to the room he
opened the door and could not believe
what he saw is this a trick how did you
do this he demanded Sophie's father
interrupted I told you my daughter is
amazing her mother was the same store
Lorne
shouted the King Sophie come with me
please the King led Sophie to another
room inside the room were ten piles of
hay if you did at once you can do it
again said the king it must be done by
morning
and this time I'm locking the door
everyone left and the door was locked
Sophie was alone all for heaven's sake
but this time Sophie knew what to do she
searched the entire room she looked high
and low she looked behind the curtains
she looked on top of the shelves little
man little man are you here just then
she heard a funny little laugh teehee
what do you have for me the little man
appeared in a corner of
room once again the little man pulled
two knitting needles out of his pockets
he started to knit the hay he knitted
golden sweaters he made golden gloves
and golden Underpants soon the hay was
gone and there was a pile of golden
clothes on the floor and now what do you
have for me
that's ruby ring suggested Sophie
perfect said the man I need a ruby ring
so if he gave her ring to the man he
said
tee-hee-hee and disappeared when the
King opened the door the next morning he
could not believe what he saw how did
you do this he yelled
no Sophie shrugged I taught myself her
to net last winter the king led Sophie
to yet another room in the palace this
room was completely full of hay from
floor to ceiling here are 100 bundles of
hay said the king and there are ten
guards outside the door this time nobody
can help you I hope you are not lying
dear Sophie the king said quietly
remember all Liars will be fed to the
crocodiles everyone left sophie was
alone and there were ten guards outside
the door again Sophie knew what to do
she searched the entire room she looked
high and low she looked under the table
she looked in the closet little man
little man where are you
but the little man wasn't there
Sophie sat down and cried soon she fell
into a deep sleep when she woke up she
couldn't believe her eyes every single
piece of hay was gone and there was a
huge pile of gold and clothes on the
floor the little man was sitting on top
of the clothes oh thank you
cried Sophie I thought it was crocodile
food for sure the little man smiled and
now what do you have for me this
sapphire bracelet said Sophie no I don't
need a bracelet these silver earrings
suggested Sophie
no I don't wear earrings
Sophie grew angry I don't have anything
else to give you
she said hmm I know what I want said the
little man many years from now give me
your first child
what no cried Sophie or hay will tell
the king you are a liar
Sophie had no other choice she agreed to
the little man's deal the King returned
when the King opened the door he was
amazed there was a huge pile of golden
clothes stacked from the floor to the
ceiling you really are amazing
you may go but maybe one day you can
teach me how to knit too
Sophie agreed she ran out of the palace
as fast as she could
ten years past Sofie grew into a clever
and accomplished woman she married a
kind man they had a baby boy one morning
Sophie was playing with her son in the
garden when she heard that strange
little laugh
what do you have for me the little man
stepped out from behind a bush no you
can't have him
screamed Sophie she held the baby close
to her chest she cried and cried we had
a deal my dear said the little man but I
will make you another deal guess my name
if you know my name
you can keep your son you have three
days is it a deal Sophie cried it's a
deal
the next night the little man returned
and Sophie guessed all the common names
is it Tim
no is it Jack no
is it Chris no the second night she
guessed some less common names is it
Balthazar
no is it fair didn't know is it Alphonso
no the third day sophie was panicking
she went for a walk in the forest to
clear her head it was already getting
late his feet are pointed like a
Norwegian she thought so maybe his name
is Bjorn but his nose is red like an
Australian so maybe his name is Keith
but his hat looks Turkish so maybe his
name is Mustafa Sophie walked deeper and
deeper into the forest she jumped over
logs and climbed over rocks and then
turned a corner she was very surprised
to see a small house a woman was sitting
on the porch
she was knitting baby clothes and
singing quietly on her neck was Sophie's
necklace on her finger was Sophie's ring
Rumpelstiltskin Rumpelstiltskin more
laughs the woman shouted can you come
here I need you to help me meet and
guess who appeared at the door it was
the little man Sophie ducked down behind
a bush how lucky she ran home as fast as
she could that night the little man came
to see Sophie he seemed very happy it's
time my dear he said so do you know my
name is it rhubarb
no is it Roquefort no is it
Rumpelstiltskin the little man's face
turned red with anger he screamed and
shouted and stomped his feet how did you
know my name how did you know my name
but then he stopped and cried he looked
up at Sophie we would have loved your
son very much he whispered the little
man wiped his tears away with a yellow
handkerchief and disappeared
[Music]
after that Sophie and a family lived
happily ever after just like in the
stories but what happened to the little
man well look closely when you hear
people telling big lies because big lies
always need a big payment
Rumpelstiltskin will usually be there
under the table or on top of the
cupboard he is always waiting to make a
good deal